open phones a triple eight eight two
five five two two five when you are
engaged folks there's all kinds of data
points out there on what indicators are
for a successful marriage and you ought
to use them a day if you're not talking
much about love I know I've seen a whole
lot of people in love get divorced and
here's the data points
there's here's the first set of data
points if you can be an agreement in
detail about how about how we're gonna
handle money how we're gonna handle your
mother and her mother the in-laws and
how we're gonna handle kids and if we're
gonna have them and we're in agreement
about religion if you've got those four
data points you're in unity on you have
a very high likelihood of having a
successful marriage those are the big
four that take people out disagreements
over kids money in-laws and religion
take people out more than anything else
if you're in unity on those things you
can tackle anything you can tackle
anything but crazy mother-in-law break
you up every time it'll do it every time
if you guys don't have aren't unified on
how you're gonna deal with her she's a
test pilot for a broom Factory and we
got a deal with her that's the thing you
know so you gotta you got to work this
out you got to have these things laid
down and you're number one cause of
divorce in North America right now money
fights and money problems
you're not unified on the number on the
way to handle the number one problem
area you are asking for trouble you're
asking for it if the number one cause of
getting killed by a bear was to walk
down willow lane you would never walk
down willow lane because people get
killed by bears there it's kind of
simple you know and that's what this is
so I have no idea if there's bears on
Willow Lane sorry if you live on willow
lane but the whole point here okay but
you see the thing if you the number one
cause of death while driving is texting
then you would stop
stupid you know you don't want to die
and you don't want to enter into
marriage when you're not on the same
track on money some big deal on your pre
marriage counseling it's a big deal
that's why a lot of pastors and a lot of
counselor marriage counselors are giving
Financial Peace University as part or
requiring it as part of their pre
marriage counseling because it forces
you to discuss the debt monster it
forces you to discuss how we're going to
save it forces you to discuss whether
we're going to pay cash for things it
forces you to discuss are we going to
have the maturity to delay pleasure or
do we have to spend everything every
weekend and act like we're stupid you
know are we gonna let forces you to
discuss that and if you can get on the
same page on that man it's a big plus
for your marriage it's a big big deal